(hard industrial rock)
- I'm here in front of the
Comfort Inn in Alton, Illinois.
On the houseboat
in the parking lot.
I have a rash between
my balls and my asshole.
(laughter)
Guys, let me just
explain something.
Wetsuit etiquette, you
pee in your wetsuit,
it's just a thing
you do, all right?
It's great, it's the only
time you get to pee in pants.
Now normally I'm in the water
when I'm wearing a wetsuit.
What I've never done is peed
in a wetsuit and then sat
on a jet ski for eight
hours, totally dry.
Because then what
happens next morning,
wake up and it looks like
someone's taken a cheese grater
to inside of your thighs
and your butt-hole.
Right?
That's right! Yeah!
- You wanna cover the rash
and everything surrounding it.
- Ugh.
And then even worse, you have
to have another grown man
help you apply ointment
to your balls and asshole.
- We're gonna apply
this a few times today.
- Oh, wow, a lot.
- All right, let's go.
We are fucking late.
(rollicking western guitar)
We've launched!
Yeah!
Mississippi River!
Take me to your lover!
First day of the trip,
fucking disaster, all right?
Ran out of gas, stuck in
a lock, butt-hole rash,
we didn't even make it half
as far as we needed to.
So day two, we need to
seriously make up for lost time.
I needed to meet Jon Daly to
do a lunchtime comedy show
in St. Louis, which
was 80 miles away.
Now, 80 miles in a car,
it's nothing, easy.
But 80 miles of jet
ski on the Mississippi?
Riding a jet ski 80 miles
is kinda like straddling
a horrible bucking horse
that shoots industrial waste
out of its own asshole.
It becomes a battle
against the river.
What do you need when you're
battling a force of nature?
Human companionship.
Wait a second, who's that?
Oh, shit!
It's Jon Daly!
- Ahhhh!
Let's go to St. Louis!
- Let's go to St. Louis!
(emotional rock music)
- Oh man, I love you America!
Welcome to St. Louis!
We made it!
The Windy City!
Arch, Arch, Arch, Arch!
- [Both] Arch! Arch! Arch!
(driving country rock)
- Get some petroleum
jelly on them?
- Supposed to dry it out,
but I don't know
why you would want
to dry your ball area out.
- I have a theory about
you, and I think it's true.
- Really?
What?
- You wanna make
your balls famous.
(laughter)
You want everyone in the world
to know how big your balls are.
- It's one of the most
interesting things about me.
- Well now it's an open secret.
- This is the water that
makes the horrible smell here.
- Does all St. Louis
smell like shit garbage,
or just this one
alley that we chose?
- It's definitely the one
alley we chose to walk down.
Ready to do this?
- Yeah.
- All right.
- Never been more ready
to do jet ski show.
- After you, buddy.
- Thank you sir.
- [Announcer] Give it up
for our dude, Jon Daly.
(audience cheers)
- Oh yeah!
Hey!
How's it going?
Big Daddy, give it up!
All right, thank so
much for coming out!
You enjoying those ribs?
- [Audience Man] Oh yeah!
- Oh yeah!
Got those ribs and bibs.
For every rib you eat today,
there's a person in Africa
that is not eating a rib.
(laughter)
The importance of what we're
doing cannot be overstated.
We're here because
of Kurt Braunohler,
the Bono of the new century.
This guy's taking over, he's
Bono without that dumb accent.
And he's not all slick and
Hollywood and full of shit!
Wearing dumb sunglasses and
getting out of limos like this.
(audience laughs)
Enjoy your ribs,
and wear your bibs.
Here he is, one of the best
people I've ever known,
Kurt Braunohler.
Ladies and gentlemen, Jon Daly!
Guys, thank you so
much for coming out.
Hello!
Guys, I did some
research about St. Louis,
and I dunno if you
guys knew this.
In 2012, 150 people were
murdered in St. Louis.
But in 2013, only 120 people
were murdered in St. Louis.
(audience applauds)
Get your shit together!
This show is for you,
the 30 people who were not
murdered in St. Louis this year.
(audience laughs)
You did it, St. Louis!
And I wanna propose
something to all of you
who are here with us right now.
I'm gonna do a publicity
stunt to get the word out
about this charity effort.
So I want you guys, the
30 people not murdered
in St. Louis this year, to pull
Jon Daly and I on a jet ski,
underneath the St. Louis Arch.
(laughter)
Who's in?
(audience cheers)
All right, half of you are in!
That's enough!
Let's go to the Arch soon!
(the storm rumbles)
(foreboding electronica)
- [Minnow] Hey guys.
- [Man] What's up?
- [Kurt] Our jet ski arrived
before we were ready.
- We got busted.
- We're getting in trouble
with the Parks Department.
It's for Comedy Central,
it's a charity show
called Roustabout.
So here we are, we're just
trying to get media attention
for the whole charity
effort, all right?
And it never occurs to
us that, I don't know,
maybe the National Parks
Service might worry about
a bunch of weirdos wheeling
stuff under a national monument.
Maybe they think we're towing
a hilarious jet ski shaped bomb.
(audience laughs)
But, we're gonna get it done.
- Pull it through, but we
pull it through illegally.
- Yeah, let's talk to them.
- Hey, I'm Kurt.
Hey nice to meet you man.
Yeah, so--
- This is when he's gotta
work that Braunohler magic.
- Yeah, work that
Braunohler charm.
- The whole thing is about like,
what's the dumbest way to
make the world a better place,
and so we were gonna make
the world a better place
in St. Louis by jet
skiing underneath the Arch
and kind of
celebrating St. Louis.
We just literally
just wanna like,
roll it through and that's it.
(thunder cracks)
- Holy shit!
(laughter)
Wow, that was insane.
- And we're sitting
there, we're all like,
no way is this happening.
What's your name again?
Jay, Kurt.
Thank you so much man.
And then this guy Jay, is just
like, sure, we can do that!
Right on, Jay!
(epic orchestral music)
(laughter)
I can't believe this
is actually happening.
- [Crew Man] Heads
up, everybody.
- St. Louis, we love ya!
- Woo!
(laughter)
- Now it was time to
break a world record,
and jet ski two comedians
under the St. Louis Arch.
(laughter)
The first to jet
ski under the Arch!
- [Jon] Yeah!
We're under the Arch!
- St. Louis!
We did it for you!
- [Jon] We're under the Arch!
- Now, this seemed like a great
idea when we thought it up.
- There's children!
- What?
To be honest,
nobody gave a shit.
The only person who
was excited about it
was a six year old girl
who didn't even know
what the fuck was going on.
- [Crew Man] Whoa.
(laughter)
But hey, sometimes you gotta
have bad ideas, all right?
Here's the four people from
St. Louis that showed up!
Although I did
make some friends.
Yeah, big hug, big group hug!
Including a nice homeless
man who just really seemed
like he wanted a hug.
- [Homeless Man] Thank you!
It has been real!
- One two three, St. Louis!
- [All] St. Louis!
- STL baby!
- Stay close to the shore.
Watch out for the bodies.
- Watch for the bodies?
- Bodies?
- And cor-uhps.
- Do the bodies
go in the middle?
- I couldn't tell you that.
(laughter)
- In short, the Arch.
Nailed it.
(ringing guitar chord)
(heavy industrial music)
- Okay, so the Arch
was a bad idea.
But you know what's a good idea?
You, clicking on this link,
and donating to
Heifer right now!
Do it!
Give some money to
these good people.
Come on!